Crime Stoppers a name you'll hear a lot
here on Channel 8 after we update you on
crime that could be happening in your
neighborhood Victoria Saha explains how
this organization quite literally helps
stop crime with the help of our viewers
and tips that follow
fighting crime is not a one person's job
it takes resources from all over to keep
our streets safe in Nevada Crime
Stoppers is a citizen media and law
enforcement Cooperative program okay
intended to include the public in
fighting crime Richard Galvin the vice
chair for Crime Stoppers of Nevada says
every bit of information coming in from
the public helps it's a great way for
people to feel secure in getting
valuable information to law enforcement
and the 2022 numbers from Crime Stoppers
of Nevada is proof that this
organization helps last year there were
several arrests made from your tips
ranging from homicide suspects to wanted
persons to narcotics even tips on deadly
hit and run crashes in total there were
72 arrests with 12 guns recovered and
more than four thousand dollars paid out
in Rewards without the help of the
citizens of our community we wouldn't be
able to identify them or we wouldn't be
able to locate them and they would
continue to be repeat offenders while
there is money readily available for
rewards Galvin says most tipsters aren't
looking for a payout we absolutely love
to pay them out we're happy to do that
as for who are the people behind Crime
Stoppers of Nevada Crime Stoppers is
made up of a group of local
Professionals in various professions uh
including media channel 8 has a board
member uh that works with us Victoria
Saha eight news now again you are
eligible for a reward if your tip leads
to an arrest you do not have to wait for
that person to be convicted if you have
any information on crime in your
neighborhood the number for Crime
Stoppers right here
702-385-55555 and of course you can stay
anonymous